I warmly welcome you.
Today we are dealing with Reneé Descart,
the great rationalist.
Maybe you know his short but
world-famous sentence. I think that means
I am. Everyone in France knows Decart because in
France, Decart is an integral part
of school lessons and with good
reason  the father of
philosophy and he definitely deserves this honorary title father
of philosophy
because you will see today there is a
world before decart and a world after
decart he basically has, like
Christopher Columbus discovered a new continent,
the new world has us
Descart showed a whole new dimension of
knowledge and because of his
discovery we see the world
with different eyes. He
basically
replaced belief with thinking, at least
for science, you have to
imagine that for over a thousand years
people in the Christian world have  The
West believed in the words of the prophets,
i.e. Moses or Abraham from the
Old Testament or in the John
prophecy from the New Testament and
of course in the word of Jesus Christ
who is of course more than just a
prophet but the Son of God and the Word
of God was in the  Holy Scripture
has been written down and for Taus
years people have taken all their knowledge
about their origins from Adam and Eve about
the cosmos and the world from Holy
Scripture and then this
röned Kart comes and writes this book
meditation is de prima philosophia
meditation  about the first philosophy
and makes an outrageous demand.
He says we can no longer just
get our knowledge from the words of the prophets and the epiphanies of the saints, but what we
need now is, I quote, a true and
secure knowledge and dekart undertakes
the immodest and radical  Trying to
find a final basis for knowledge,
a kind of Archimedean point from which
one can then recognize,
analyze and control the entire world. I
quote nothing but an
immovable point, Archimedes demanded
in order to move the entire earth from its place
and so I can also hope very much
I find even the slightest thing
that is certain and unshakable
dercart asks the fundamental
question is there one point that is absolutely
certain and unshakable the
answer you all know it is his the
little sentence I think so I am what
this little sentence means and how  came to this
and why the sentence
is so important I will
explain it in a moment. At the moment the only important thing for us is
that Decart takes its starting point for
its philosophy from thinking purely from thinking.
Thinking is the
essential quality of human beings.
Thinking is the only thing that can be done  I can't
be separated from me, so I'm just
a thinking being and this new
philosophy in this book by
making thinking the basis of science and his
philosophy had
three big consequences. The first consequence was
a consequence for him
personally, of course he now had to  Be
afraid for life uh because
uh it could of course be that he would be
accused of heresy and burned,
which
actually happened at the time and hold on to your guns,
he had 20 different
residences, he first moved from Catholic
France to slightly more liberal Holland
and in the end even to
Protestant France  Sweden and he did
n't tell anyone where he lived. He
always remained hidden and
kept his place of residence secret. Only his best
friend Meren knew where he
was from time to time and this concern was
of course not entirely unfounded because
either the belief applies or it applies
that  Thinking and he was a rationalist the
ratio so thinking was being and
both together is of course difficult
but we'll get to that and his
concern was of course not entirely
unfounded because when he was
writing this book he even wrote
this little one before the meditations
Treatise that also
has the telling title Treatise on
the method of thinking correctly, so
here too he is again concerned with the
method of thinking correctly and as he is
currently writing this little book, you
can see that it is very
thin, he hears that at the same time a
contemporary  by him namely Galilee
Galileo
Galileo was accused of heresy
because Galileo claimed that the earth
would turn on itself and
of course Galileo called everything back
and said yes, yes, that was nonsense, I
honored myself and that meant he was
n't burned, but still because he  After he
first claimed it, he was
sentenced to life imprisonment. When the person
heard that, he tore up parts of the
book and burned it and
then only published the rest, but
not under his own name but under
a pseudonym so as not to have the same
fate. The second one
Of course it did have a bit of an impact,
but after his death shortly after his
death, all of his books were banned,
both by the French king
and by the Pope
founded a new science, namely
epistemology, he was the first to
ask how do we come to really
certain knowledge and since then there has been
this new science of
epistemology that asks the same question
and today I will give you
a history of epistemology in
5 minutes, starting from
Rationalism from Descart to the
empiricists to Immanuel Kant up to today
you will also find out what we think is
correct and true today. The third major
consequence of this book was the famous
Cartesian
dualism, you could also say the
Decartche dualism because it is named after Descart,
the cathesian one
Dualism Descart had explained that
there are only two substances in the entire universe,
the so-called res
extensa, the extended substance, so
that's all the table, the
packages, the chairs, the bodies, the
plants, the stones, the animals, also our
bodies, the planets of the universe, that
's extended  Matter extended
substance R extensor and then there is
the R cogitanz that is the second
substance our spirit our thinking our
reason and the core idea in this
dualism is now with decart that
with the possibilities of reason and
thinking we can control the entire external nature the
extensa the  We have to
recognize, analyze and master all of external nature.
We can use the extensa, which
we literally say, to become the lord and master of
nature
and you will see
that in our European DNA we have
this dualism that is still
there, but it had many great
philosophical discoveries  positive
consequences but also disastrous ones as we will
see in a moment. First of all I would like to
introduce him to the core of this wonderful book. Meditation
is de prima philosophia why
meditations on the first philosophy
When we think of meditation we all always
first think of Buddha or the
Buddhists  sitting cross-legged
and meditating and
the Buddha actually had his
great realizations, his
enlightenment under a fig tree
in a completely secluded valley, he
withdrew into solitude
and meditated and in four
meditations came to this realization of
eternal becoming and passing away  of the
universe and nirvana Decart
also meditated but not in a
cross-legged position. He retreated to a
remote country house and
sat in an armchair in front of the open
fireplace and Decart needed six
meditations so this book has six
different meditations which is new about
the book  You'll see in a moment that he
describes it to us a bit like
a novel, it's not a classic
philosophical book,
it's almost written in the literary style of
a diary,
he describes his meditations to us and
what he discovered is also written
by him in French
published in French, completely
untypical for his time, normal,
only good for the educated elite, in
Latin, and as he
retreats into solitude he says, first of
all, I have to free myself from all the prejudices
that I learned and heard out in the world
and
for this we need a new method,
namely the method of radical
doubt.
We cannot free ourselves from prejudices other
than by forcing ourselves to
doubt everything in which we encounter even the
slightest suspicion of uncertainty.
We have to doubt everything in
which we even have  encounter the slightest
suspicion of uncertainty and
that's why this first meditation begins
with him sitting down in his
armchair and thinking about what
I normally consider to be beyond
doubt and as real and real and
he comes up with the simple idea that and
for all of us it is like that  here in the hall
and for me that we generally
consider what we
see with our own eyes, hear, smell,
taste and touch to be real and real, so our five
senses usually give us the feeling for
reality, so the dekat
quote says everything that I have so far  What
I think is most likely to be true is thanks to the senses or the mediation of the
senses, but then he just sits in his
armchair and doubts and
thinks about it. Are the senses really so
reliable and then several
thoughts come up, so not everything
we see is always correct?
Hold a stick in a pond under water
then it looks like it's broken on
the surface of the water and in reality it
's just the stick, it
's just the optical effect of the
refraction of light in the water that makes us think it's
broken, so the senses can
deceive us
or even if we see a church tower
perhaps made of copper,
the gold shines in the midday sun and in the
evening it looks reddish but it is
red again and still golden so the senses
can deceive us and the famous
example that decart gives us here is
the example of
beeswax  we look at this piece of
wax, it is hard and cold, you can
touch it easily and if you hit it with your
knuckle it makes a sound. It
has everything you need to
make any body very clearly recognizable, but while I'm
still talking you're approaching it  The
smell of the fire disappears, the color changes,
it becomes misshapen, it gets bigger, it becomes
liquid. So the senses don't help us
much when we
look at the wax, sometimes we see it
liquid, sometimes we see it solid, so
we can never be
100% sure
leave our sense perceptions, that's why
he says and now I've
discovered that these five senses
sometimes deceive us and it is a
commandment of prudence never to completely
trust those who have deceived us even once
and he basically says whoever lies once
believes them  you can't and even if he
speaks the truth and that's how we have to
do it with our five senses,
yes, once you've cheated us,
we can never rely on it 100% again,
but then another thought comes to him
if you
continue to doubt and think about it  Is
everything
unreal that the senses show and so
then he says, well, distant objects
like a church tower or something like that,
the senses can deceive us or when the
growth is a bit gone but my own
hands my body is there when
I  I have such a paper in my hand and
that's why he says that
even though our senses
deceive us when it comes to distant objects, there
are many other things that one ca
n't doubt, for example that I'm
sitting by the fireplace in my winter coat, that
I'm holding this paper with my hands  Betaste how
could you deny that to me?
So when he touches this paper
then you have to say that it's
really real but then he has
a terrible
doubtful thought. It could be that I'm
just dreaming that I'm sitting here by the fireplace
with my winter coat and this paper in  in my
hand, how do I even know
that I'm not just seeing dream images and that I'm
actually lying in bed and
sleeping? How can I find a reliable
license plate and then he does something
crazy, he keeps throwing his head back and forth
and it even cracks and then he
thinks  he, well, now I already have
the feeling that I'm awake, this head
that I move back and forth is
not sleeping so clearly, but this doesn't happen to me
in my
sleep, but then he thinks about it and thinks,
well, I could have dreamed the cracking myself
and  Maybe you
all know this wonderful song by the
Austrian songwriter Wolfgang
Ambros, he always sings like this. I think I'm
dreaming. I think it
's not allowed  This
helps us to recognize for sure that we
are awake and not dreaming because
even if someone pinches us now and
we feel the pain, it could be
that we are feeling the pain.
Sometimes we dream about pain, so even that
is not a sure sign and then
it comes  I think about the result
more carefully here and
I see very clearly that being awake and
dreaming
can never be distinguished by certain characteristics
and if you really doubt then
it is like this, we already have all the
feeling here but we are here together in the same
room
So you probably know that too,
I experienced that in my
childhood, but I always
dreamed that I could float, so now
I couldn't fly or something like that. I could only
float over the bed, not much,
maybe 12,200,150, yes, and then
I woke up  and then
I thought, ah, now I'll try it out to see if
I can actually float. At first
it didn't work, but then I
concentrated with all my strength and
I actually took off and then
I wanted to call the family and
show off my new abilities and in  At that
moment I really woke up and
the tragedy was that I woke up in a dream
but that was also a dream
of waking up and that I
could really float yes and so that's why
he says here the descart I think about
it carefully so I see it
very clearly  that there are no sure
signs that really tell us
whether we are awake at the moment, but because he
is an old thinker and doubter,
he continues to think in his
armchair whether there
is any truth in the dream and then
the thought occurs to him that we are often leftovers from the day
dream what we experienced the day before
and that the things we dream are
somehow
depicted from real circumstances,
er I'll quote it like this, you have to
admit that there are images seen in our sleep
that could only be depicted in the pattern of true
things in our
sleep  Seen are things that emerge based on
true models or patterns.
If, for example, we
dream of a winged horse, then
the horse is a true
reality based on the pattern we dreamed in the dream
and the wing is also true,
so the birds
only have wings  the composition is deceiving us,
the dream is the combination of these
two properties, the flying horse is
deceiving us, but says
decart and then something really funny happens
that can only happen to a mathematician,
so decart was also a mathematician, he
has the coordinate system from him
with the
I'm dreaming
or awake, that could be a final
certainty because geometry and
arithmetic are not based on
concrete properties like wings
or horses, but rather the numbers, which are
quite abstract from the
numbers and then at first he thinks
maybe it's arithmetic and
geometry  a final Archemedean
point of knowledge I like waking or
sleeping so 2 + 3 = 5
and he then concludes from this one
can rightly conclude from this
that arithmetic is geometry which
only deals with the most general objects
which contain something of undoubted certainty
and  Then he thinks that
perhaps he has found something with his arithmetic
that is certain, but then
a new doubt occurs to him. You see, he
exercises the doubt radically because he
knows that all additions and
subtractions are based on axioms,
all mathematics and geometry are also
based on them  Axioms on which everything is
based and the thought suddenly occurs to you:
what if the axioms
themselves are wrong, what if an
evil spirit, an extraterrestrial power,
imports and manipulates a false matrix for us
and all our axioms
are wrong. Decart is talking about this
a genius malignus from an evil
spirit and if there were such a thing and
with his doubt he wants to
rule out everything that is doubtful but if
there were such a thing we would also have to
doubt that our axioms of
mathematics are correct and the quote is
something I will assume  The evil
spirit has put all its effort into
deceiving me, just as
I could be deceiving myself as often as I add two and
three together,
as you can see, he has
no certainty there either and at the end of this
first
meditation he is quite confused, he
is quite unfounded because he lets it go  you ca
n't rely on the five senses, they
deceive us and you can never
say with certainty whether you're dreaming
or awake and thirdly, you ca
n't even rely on the axioms of mathematics
and geometry - it could all be
one  be a subversively well-rehearsed matrix
that we have had since we were born or
have had it for generations. Everything is
possible and because of that he decides to
no longer perceive anything
that he cannot prove with certainty and
comes to the conclusion that I want to believe that
heaven, air, earth and all external things
are nothing but  the deceptive game
of dreams I want to
look at myself as if I have no hands, no
eyes, no flesh, no blood is a
hard sentence. He sits in his
armchair and two
whether everything isn't a deception and
says to himself, I want to
look at myself as if I had  I have no end no
legs no flesh and blood he is close
to madness and completely exhausted he goes to
bed after this first meditation the next day he gets up and
then comes the famous second
meditation the second meditation
ladies and gentlemen is the most quoted one
Chapter of a philosophical book
worldwide and this second meditation
begins with an admission. He sits down
in his armchair and says yesterday's
reflection plunged me into
enormous doubts, like
falling into a deep
whirlpool. He recapitulates that
first day again and remembers why he  was
drawn into such a whirlpool and
remembers that he was
n't able to
find anything solid and
says he has to continue
building on that, there's no other way. Quote
So I'm assuming that everything I
see is wrong, body shape  Movement
and place are nothing but chimeras.
So what is
true left? What is true
left? Now in this second meditation,
Decart stands in front of the rubble of his
doubt. A huge pile of shards
lies in front of him. With the club of doubt,
he has
first smashed the sensory perception and
said it  There is no
certainty then he swung the club again
and shattered the certainty
that we are awake, we
could also be dreaming and finally
he used the club of doubt to doubt even
the basics of AR tics and geometry
and now he is standing in front of this
pile of shards  completely frustrated and
asks the question what
truth is left and for a short time he thinks
maybe there is no Archemedean
point, maybe there is no
ultimate certainty in human life but
then the scales fall from his
eyes and then his big realization comes to him,
that of  always
swinging the club, this me who has
doubted every time, that has doubted the senses, that has
doubted whether
he is awake or dreaming, the one who
has swung the club, this me is
always the same me, this me is
certain when I
doubt and doubting is yes  only
critical thinking if I have doubts then there
must be me there must be me
quote he is deceiving me so by he means
the dream and the genius
malignus it no
longer matters whether we are now dreaming
or whether a genius malignus is deceiving us
At the moment when I doubt everything there has
to be me, that's what he says in
this quote, he's deceiving me as much as he
can, he'll never manage to make sure
I'm nothing as long as I think, no matter
whether we're dreaming or an evil
spirit is deceiving us  in the moment when
we doubt I am there in the moment when
I think critically or when I doubt there is
me there must
be me and so I finally come to
the conclusion that this sentence
is me I exist as often as I
say it or in my mind  What was
necessary
is a thinking person, a thinking person
can make mistakes in many things, he can make mistakes, he
can be wrong, but the
fact that he thinks and can be wrong,
this fact still means that
he has to exist at the moment when he
thinks and that's where he comes to  his
famous sentence I think so I am they
could also put it there I doubt
so I am because at that moment there has to be
us being
able to do a cross-check when
they are dead they no longer doubt it
can no longer be that they are dreaming in a
dream  how they doubt and in
reality they don't, but as long as they
doubt and think critically, they exist
and from this sentence, which
is an Archedemedian point from this
sentence, he now develops his entire
philosophy quote, so I believed this
sentence without any concerns  to be able to accept the first
principle of the philosophy I was looking for,
now of course he had a
problem, he developed his entire
philosophy from the certainty of
thinking, hence also rationalism,
rational reason and now he had a
huge pr because ladies and gentlemen, what about
God  Don't you have to
doubt God and he knew that it would
be very, very dangerous for him if he did
n't solve this problem now and then
the kart did something, should I say,
very good, he fled
to the front and tried the
theological faculty  in Paris
and he even dedicates this book
here on the very first page
he writes I brought it with me to
the very wise and illustrious gentlemen of the
holy theological faculty in Paris
and dedicates it to the theologians and is
already sending you several copies in advance in order to be able to do so
from the beginning
To include the church and of course it would
n't have been enough to just dedicate it to them, he
does something else, he makes a
proof of God, that's the third
meditation and this proof of God, of course,
decat wanted to kill two birds with
one stone. On the one hand,
he wanted to get out of the loop  He is a
heretic because he proves that
God definitely exists and at the same time
he was able to remain true to his rationalism
because he does not say that
God exists because a prophet says so,
but because he
can prove completely rationally with logical reasons that
he does  and this proof of God
is very interesting and
I'll show you that briefly, um maybe we'll
start with an
experiment because Decart says we all
have an idea of ​​God, so I'll
briefly say this term and
then take a look  idea they
then have in their head. Respect
God, we all basically have similar ideas when it comes to this term,
eternity,
perfection,
omniscience,
omnipotence, we have these ideas
from God and we all have them in
our heads, which means that the idea of
God is always the same for all of us  God
is in the idea eternally
infinitely omniscient and
omnipotent and now he does something
interesting he says, well, of course we have
a lot of ideas in our heads
and ultimately our
minds always work in such a way that we derive the ideas
from deeper causal ideas that
have  a bit from Plato that there are
more causal ideas that
are more perfect than the idea we are
currently thinking I quote it when we subject the
ideas we have within us to
further examination
we find that the more perfection they have in them, the more perfect their cause
must be
I'll tell you a little
different example then it will be
accepted more clearly. You have the idea of ​​a
plate or a discus disc in
ancient times or you have the idea of ​​a
silver coin and want a silver coin,
a discus disc or a
plate made of clay  Assuming we
are producers, we need a
clear idea of ​​what we
want to create, but there is something causal about this idea that we now
have in our heads. The
reason for all three ideas is the more perfect idea
of ​​roundness, the roundness without
the roundness  no coin, no plate,
no discus and the roundness is
actually a more perfect idea, you
know the mathematicians have presented this
beautiful ideal figure of the
geometric body,
um, if you have the roundness of a
circle, every point is exactly the same
distance from the center  like
everyone else, that is the fundamental
idea of ​​roundness and when we
make our silver coin, our
clay plate or the discus, they
all deviate from this idea because
you can never get them to
be mathematically round
Anyway, there are a
few small errors or the one that
tells the discus disc or GRZ from the tone
is never exact and that's why
the underlying causal idea is
more perfect than the current idea and
now the decard says let's take a look at
what it's like with God  As
we said, God is eternally
omnipotent, completely omniscient and
now let's look within ourselves for
a causal idea that
is even more perfect and of higher quality than
this idea and we said we ca
n't find anything because how do you want
an idea within yourself in a human being  find that
is even more perfect than perfection
omniscience omnipotence there we find
nothing in ourselves and that is why the idea cannot
come from us and we humans
are not omnipotent anyway
perfect everything else yes and that is why
we cannot find this idea in ourselves so
it has to  come from outside Quote because
we now in no way encounter those highest perfections
whose idea we possess within ourselves,
we
rightly conclude that they are present in something else
different from us, namely in God,
so the idea cannot come from ourselves
like they do  Roundness comes from
ourselves but the idea of
perfection does not and it has to
come from outside and it can only
come from God.
Conclusion he says we can think God
so he must exist. From today's
perspective the logicians would say it is
a  Circular reasoning at least he
assumes he already presupposes what he
wants to prove, he considers the idea of ​​God
to be real and absolute reality and
says that this idea of ​​God in our heads
definitely has a real
equivalent and then of course it is
easy for him  then
derives from this that God must exist because he
already puts the idea as real and in which
you put the idea as real he
could also say it's a
crazy idea he doesn't make the idea is
absolutely true and therefore it is logical
that there is God  Logicians would
say the proof doesn't
really work and in the end de Kart
failed doubly. On the one hand,
it's logically questionable. On the other hand,
the Catholic theology at the
sbon didn't find it funny. They did
n't think it was good because they said
you can only do it  Don't doubt God
rationally and then use
arguments to bring him back logically.
The decisive factor is direct belief in
God and
so he had to continue to hide
and live in secret and as I said
shortly after his death all of
his books were banned anyway. Before that it was
always like that on the  Kippe and that's
tragic weldeekart believed in God
at least the majority of biographers
say decart was a believer and actually I
think he also wrote to a
friend to
mercen that he believes when our body
dies our body is just
resextense expanded matter and if
that  When the body dies, the
rescogitance remains, yes, the spirit, our spirit,
our ratitio, it is not
affected by it, it lives on, I quote,
and even though I have a body, it
is still the case that I am only a thinking,
non-extended being, so much is
certain that I
I am truly different from my body and
can exist without it. Now we are
back to this Cartesian dualism
between res extensa and res cogitanz
and because he has completely separated the two substances, the
thinking substance and the
physical substance,
he was even asked how
The game
works together when I get up in the morning
and go, let's say, to the
bathroom, then the responsibility, the
reason, must somehow be
able to tell the legs that the legs
are going towards the bathroom, so the
substances can't be completely separated and
he then brings this himself  Example,
this is a drawing here, this is a
drawing by Dekat himself, um, and
you can see someone
burning his foot and he literally says, for
example, the foot nerves are moved violently, so the movement that
passes through the spinal cord gives
the mind a sign to
feel something and  causes the mind
to eliminate its cause, so it
works like a hydraulic
system and at that time there was
also an attempt because people and
animals were trying to understand everything mechanically. The
attempt was there and of course you should
n't underestimate Decart he has
with his  Rationalism
paves the way for an unleashing
natural science, one has to say, and
of course it already started in his time.
Contemporaries of decart
goods
Kepler
Galileo Galileo also
invented the binoculars and F fiber thermometer
or Newton was also a later
contemporary with his mechanics and that
Gravity with Newton thought
we finally recognized the world and then
I also found Euronymus Fabritius exciting, he was a surgeon
who had already dissected corpses and
with Decart you know,
burying corpses is no longer a sin because that's what
the body is  only R extensa,
that is not a sin, that
is not a matter of fetching corpses, that is just
science. We have to understand external nature
through understanding, analyzing and
mastering it, and this surgeon, the
ironymus Fabritius,
even discovered around 1600 why there are
stillbirths and has very nicely
advanced embryonic science
It could be that the embryo
has the umbilical cord around the neck or around the
shoulder and so on and here
we also see something interesting: the
manikin. It is assumed that this
manikin was used by him for training purposes
because you can see
the resextensor very nicely  You
can show all the joints how they
work, you can twist them and see
how they work on this
joint pump and you can already see the
enormous advance of science
to penetrate everything. What is also interesting about
this Cartesian dualism is that Descart, er,
counts the animals entirely as R extensors
So humans have R kogitan and
rextenser, we have bodies and minds,
animals don't, animals function as
delicately as automatons, like wind-up
primordial works, and sometimes we have the
feeling that humans are such animals more than
an automaton, but that's what they think too, but that's what they
say  Kat, we're wrong, I'll
quote, it's strange that many
animals show two more dexterity in individual tasks
than we do,
but it follows that they have an understanding
falls from the tree backwards falls from the tree then
turns and lands on all
fours and the dekat would say that's
not that the rkogitan has
thought and thought about it on all fours
I hurt myself the least and turns
around but nature turns the
cat  In the cat,
nature works and turns it onto all fours, but
it is basically inanimate, it is a
pure body, pure eres extensa and as a
result of this rather dangerous
thinking that it is extenses,
animals have also been built. People have
tried to recreate animals  Because,
as the K says, they supposedly only
work like wind-up original works and
here you can see the
scientific At the end of 1773, the
Frenchman schacte vocon
voonson built
the first mechanical duck out of over 400 movable individual parts
with which it was hugely celebrated
throughout France that science
This duck could finally build animals
because it could
actually walk a little bit, it
could flap its wings, it
could g so it could chatter and
of course Voccasan made a huge show
out of it, he then scattered some grains there
and ate the grains at the end, to
huge applause  and then after
a while the duck excreted
again huge applause because the duck
digested everything. Well later they
found out that the duck
couldn't digest it at all. He had
installed two containers, one container where the
grains were sucked in and a second
container where  There was already such a green
excrement prepared that was then delayed like
a clock,
so voocasson has,
so to speak, yes, I don't want to
say shitty, he cheated and
but why am I telling you that now,
not
because he cheated, but so that you
can see the euphoria that he had back then  In
science, the giant extensor was, we have to
recognize and manipulate, recreate,
master, yes, that was the
big idea and that's why Ren
Decart says we now need exactly
this departure with our rextensa with
our reason, he says by means of it
we can gain knowledge  which
are extremely useful for life and
thus make us the lords and masters of nature
and today we have actually
made progress with our knowledge
that is extremely useful for our lives,
so we shouldn't talk it down
if
we have one  If we have plague then we take a
strong antibiotic or if we have syphilis
or other bacterial
diseases, medicine is much more
advanced than it used to be and our comfort is also
allowed so we have harvesters, we
have fertilizers, we have pesticides,
fungicides, we produce them in ways we never
imagined and we shower in the
Of course, early warm weather was
not possible at all during the decade and
of course we can do that by
using fossil energies to control and
exploit them, but you can see that
we are slowly reaching a limit with catesthetic
dualism - although
we still think this way  there we are, there
is nature but in the meantime my decade
knew nothing about
global warming and the greenhouse effect,
but today it is actually the case
that we have to rethink a bit,
that we are not only the lords and
masters of nature but we
have to try to  To become a player in nature
or a guardian of nature,
we are now slowly coming to an end to the
catesthetic
dualism. Now I'll show you what
Decat achieved by
founding the theory of knowledge and
show him the development
of the theory of knowledge in the 5 minutes I have
here for you  he once brought descart with him
founded rationalism. Rationalists were Spinoza
Malbran Leibnitz and
Wolf and as you know decart tells us
that it depends on the
rationality with the understanding therefore
rationalism to see the truth the
senses are of no use and that's why quote
he says I know  that bodies are not
known through the senses but only through the mind, not by
seeing them but by
thinking things, so we
do not know things by
seeing them but by thinking them. He
gives another example when the  When the sun
goes down you see a little
red ball and my senses tell me that when
I stand on the huge earth and see
mountains and all
sorts of things, I have the feeling that the sun
is much smaller than the earth but the
thinking astronomers say the decart the
thinking ones  and calculating astronomers
say no no the sun is bigger than
the earth just by thinking we recognize
reality it is completely different with the
empiricists what does empir mean is also
Latin that means
following experience the empiricists consequences of
experience Lock Bacon hops Berkley and
humum were the ones  important empiricists
and they say exactly the opposite
of dekart only what we can look at,
touch, can
experience sensually where we can
do experiments only the
experiences that help us to gain real
knowledge and Bacon, for example, a great
empiricist who tried
to preserve poultry meat
Refrigeration and, among other things, helped
himself in refrigeration houses and also by hand
and stuffed ice cream or
snow into the dead poultry to
preserve them
and repeatedly ate thawed poultry
and in one of these attempts
he died and yes they laugh but
that  didn't harm his fame,
he was a good empiricist because that
helped us again,
yes, in the end it's the experience
and the empiricists in turn
don't deny that reason exists
then they say that there really is reason
but there is reason  is just a
blank bowl so I'll quote it
here it is still here nothing is in the
mind that's from John Lock the quote
nothing is in the mind that hasn't
been in the senses before nothing is in
our mind that hasn't been in
the senses before  So what came in is the
ratio of the K is basically an
empty bowl and since birth we've been putting
experiences and perceptions in there
otherwise there wouldn't be anything in it that was
the argument between empiricists
and rationalists who is right,
the rationalists or the empiricists
and  That's where the philosopher Immanuel Kant comes
into play and tells us that we are right
and both are wrong, it's a
both and we need in
science the experimental setups,
constant experiments and we have to
write it down, measure it and then
we have to do what we see in the view
have perceived
process with the Z categories of the
mind then our reason kicks
in and processes what we have seen
we need both because if
we only had the views then we would
get lost in the chaos of sensory impressions because we would have
chaotic sensory impressions first the
reason does all of this  assigns,
assigns into causalities and so on
leads to knowledge and, conversely, if we had
only reason without
intuition, what should reason
think about if it
has no intuition and I brought him the
most important quote from Immanuel in
this regard without
sensuality  No object would be given to us
and without understanding no one would
be thought. Thoughts without content are empty.
Views without concepts are blindly
clear. Yes, thoughts without content. So if
I just think, but I have nothing at all to
think about, there I am. That
's empty. The head is empty  And if,
on the other hand, I only have ideas
that I can't process at all,
then we are basically blind and we
need both. He created the
basis of the natural sciences
that we still have today because
nature, scientists always have to
do their experiments and disclose
them  They have to reveal the questions they ask about the
object they are investigating
and they have to reveal their method,
the method of thinking, how they then
brought the whole thing into theory.
Both have to be revealed and
both lead to the process of knowledge, but there is
still a final step
am I at the end of the
epistemology of the history of
epistemology namely the
Austrian thinker Sir poppa his
Austria English thinker was
ennobled in England himself a
natural scientist who said
well it's true we need
empiricism and reason how can say
but who empiricism is e.g
Our
scientific knowledge is always changing and there
are no absolutely certain
scientific findings
e.g. an example from poppa all swans
are white that was a scientific
truth for hundreds of years because
all over the world the
adult swans were
white and then in Patagonia they have them
Black swans were found for the first time on an expedition
and then the sentence was
no longer valid and so
dad says it's everywhere, even if
we see some other movements in the universe with ever better results
that don't fit into the expansion of the
universe, you have to use the
theory  rethink it again and even
Newton, who was considered a god, so Newton
had all the mechanics, people
thought that was the explanation of the world and
then had to be replaced in many ways by Einstein
and that's why poppa comes
to the conclusion that we have it in the
safest, best science  everything has
to do with conjectural knowledge;
scientific progress consists
in finding errors and replacing them with something
better with a better
hypothesis, so we can only ever
put forward hypotheses and every researcher
and scientist must also be
aware that what they recognize will
eventually be replaced by even better ones
Explanations
could be replaced and at the very
end I want to introduce you to the
Cartesian doubt again, it
is more valuable than you think that we
make doubt the basic method in this little book in this
treatise he already has this idea about it
in the treatise on the  Method
to
think correctly and he says ultimately he
always uses a fourfold
doubt method and I brought that to you he
says so there are
four rules the first rule was never to
accept a thing for W without
knowing it exactly as such, the second
was  to break down each question into as much simpler ones as
possible, the third was that
I started with the simplest objects
and only gradually
examined the complicated ascent, and
finally, fourthly, to count everything completely
in order to protect myself against any overlooking,
so for us now are only
the first  Both rules are important,
namely never to believe a thing to be true
without knowing it exactly as such
and
secondly to break down every complex fact
into the individual parts before we believe it
and to check the individual parts to see
whether they
are even correct then the effect at the end
still see if you haven't overlooked anything
and I'll now give him an example
of why we absolutely need this catesthetic doubt even today.
You know,
in the
media age we live in a society in
which we are always confronted with new narratives
. I would even go so far as to  Let's say we live in
a
narrative society and this is precisely where
this Cartesian doubt is more than
necessary. I would now like to show you this using
an example that has
become sadly famous, namely
the speech of the American
Secretary of State Colin Paul before the
World Security Council and the entire
world press  Here you can see the
American Secretary of State
holding a model of an
anthrax pathogen in his hand, so he already
said that it was just a model, but he wanted to
show that
this anthrax pathogen
was being produced in Iraq under Saddam Hussein and held it up to the
cameras and the whole thing  The speech
he gave there had the meaning
that the UN gives a mandate for the
invasion of Iraq to disarm
Iraq because Iraq is supposedly
producing biological chemical and nuclear weapons which endangers the entire world
and Colin
Paul does not have this mandate with his speech
because the UN had its own inspectors on site
who found nothing, but he
actually succeeded in getting
Great Britain to take part in the war of aggression
and the coalition of the
willing, which was over 30 states that
supported the attack on Iraq
and at the beginning of his speech  In front of the
world public, Colin Paul says I
brought you here literally yes,
what I present to you today is based
on facts and solid sources, these are
not allegations, what we give you
are facts and conclusions that
are based on solid intelligence work and Colin
Paul then has a Powerpoint
presentation  held or a
slide presentation with 24 slides and
some recorded radio messages
and telephone recordings and
these 24 slides actually had a
total of 24 slides. When you saw them like that,
you thought that Iraq was actually extremely
dangerous, but I say that
if you had doubted that,
you would have had doubts  We must never believe these slides,
we know about the
first and second rules: firstly, never
accept a thing as true without knowing it
exactly as such,
secondly, break down every question to be examined
into as much simpler ones as possible
for a better answer
and I would say that you would have
this  24 slides were all
looked at individually and checked to see if there really
was evidence. We might
have come to the conclusion that there wasn't and there
might not have
been a coalition of the willing with over 30 states.
I'll just show you three
slides, yes Colin Paul once has this
slide  presented that was a
satellite image in reality not
much sharper than what you
see now and someone then
drew with a red
box like that made four red boxes
and wrote here on the left
active active chemical
ammunition bunkers but active chemical
ammunition bunkers  If we doubt
what we are seeing here, at first we only see
a blurry photo and someone who
has drawn something on it with a felt tip pen and even
worse it is now getting more dramatic
here, for example on the slide, Colin
Powell said that
a decontamination
vehicle was discovered up here decontamination
vehicle and because
you need a decontamination vehicle like this to
clean yourself again and
free yourself from warfare agents if you have
come into contact with it and that's why
he concluded that this
must be a chemical ammunition bunker. Afterwards you noticed
that it was actually an FB picture  What was
shown was in black and white. If it had been
shown in color, you would have seen
that it was just a fire engine, but
it worked. It's crazy and
even worse, I think this slide is
also a
proof slide because you know, the UN had its
own experts  on site and observers
and they didn't find anything, neither
chemical, biological nor nuclear
weapons and Colin Powell said, well,
they don't find anything because
Iraq and Saddam Hussein
have mobile
production facilities for biological
weapons and you can see that here, for
example  a truck like that, they build
the biological warfare agents in the truck
or in railway wagons and whenever
the uninspectors come, the
railway wagon drives away and the truck
drives away but this drawing, if you
doubt that again, it's
just a drawing that a graphic designer
made by every twelve year old  can
make such a drawing and the
Foreign Minister said yes, it's just a
drawing but the drawing was
made according to the information of a
defector who has to be kept top secret
because otherwise he would be in danger
and that's why you know that they
have these weapons and all  If we had
looked at the slides individually they would not have
had this convincing power if we had
stuck to the Cartesian doubt. After the war
nothing was actually found in Iraq
and uh Colin Paul then admitted
that uh his talk was, so to speak, a lie
and was based on nothing and  He
said yes, he himself had been deceived
by the secret service, but he took protection from the head
of the American secret service,
that a very
honorable man, it must have happened in the middle,
low levels, yes,
madness or at least you have to
admit that Colin Pavel did in his
memoirs  He wrote that what he did
hurts him and
that it would be a stain on his
political career, but
ladies and gentlemen, this stain has
cost the lives of half a million people and that's why it's so important. That's why
it's so immensely important that
we  doubt and even if you see some satellite image in the
news again
where someone
draws something and then it says in red what that is, you
doubt,
you doubt, yes and in general it is
important that we always
maintain a free-floating doubt
because critical thinking is
the same  Doubt is nothing other than
philosophy, philosophizing means
thinking critically, I
quote, living without philosophizing
is actually like keeping your eyes
closed and never
trying to open them and so we have to
go through life with our eyes open and
always keep this one central thing in mind  Descart's sentence
visualize I am a
thinking being, that is, a being that
doubts many
[applause]
thank you